we're going to talk today about lambda
which is the symbol for the cosmological
constant of course
relativity is due to einstein albert
einstein and back in 1915 he produced
his theory of general relativity which
explains how the universe is evolving it
it explains the interaction of matter
obviously it was a brand new theory and
one of the nice things you can do when
you've got a brand new theory is that
you can play around with the equations
and
change them around to see what
consequences they have at that time in
around 1915 there was no evidence that
the universe itself was evolving if you
looked up at the night sky with the
telescopes that were available
you couldn't see that far really you
could see within the milky way and you
could see maybe
nearby andromeda galaxies and and they
were not moving relative to one another
the stars remained fixed relative to one
another on the night sky
yet einstein's theories the theory of
relativity
when applied to the universe refused to
let the universe be static
it had kept having the universe evolving
which meant in terms of the galaxies
they'd be moving apart from one another
for example
and
einstein didn't like this it clearly
wasn't fitting what he
he was observing and and colleagues were
observing about the universe so
he introduced an extra term and you kind
of have the freedom to do that it's like
if you're measuring
the how far you know if i said i travel
north for three hours at four miles an
hour
uh then i can you know i can tell you
how far i travel and it doesn't matter
where i started the distance i travel is
going to be the same and but where i
actually get to
depends on where i started from and so
you can kind of play around with
equations in that sort of way you can
actually add in constants as instead of
starting from nottingham i could start
in new york and those kinds of things so
it's that kind of thing that you didn't
actually change the laws of physics that
much by introducing this constant but it
sort of introduced an extra aspect to
the equations
but then over the next few years people
began to realize the universe was
expanding through
better telescopes being able to observe
further into the universe and they
realized the galaxies were moving apart
from one another so you interpret that
as the universe expanding
and this is so you don't need this
cosmological constant remember
einstein's original model
had the universe expanding and at that
point he famously said that this was the
biggest mistake he ever made by
introducing this constant term if he
hadn't have introduced the cosmological
constant and he'd have just trusted his
theory he would have predicted the
universe he's expanding what a
prediction that would have been
and but he didn't he tried to stop it so
it then sort of lapsed everyone assumed
well actually we can just set this term
to zero because we don't need it to
balance out the force of gravity and for
the next best part of a century it was
set to zero because it wasn't really
needed meanwhile along alongside
relativity which is dominating our
understanding of gravity
the other big success story of the 20th
century was quantum mechanics
unfortunately um
for the cosmological constant
every time there is some sort of
transition in quantum mechanics you
expect there to be
an effective cosmological constant so
even though you might decide you're
going to set it to zero
in quantum theory there's no reason why
it should be zero in fact you expect
there to be a cosmological constant
what's worse is you expect the
cosmological constant to actually be
very large
so large that if it were present it
would have either caused the universe to
rip itself apart it would have expanded
so fast
um we wouldn't be here to
even make this video
so it's not there right it's it's not
there but in the quantum theory in
particular in what's known as quantum
field theory these terms are there and
the cosmological constant problem which
is perhaps one of the biggest problems
in in physics is trying to understand
why this these contributions that come
from quantum theory aren't seen today in
the universe the universe is expanding
and accelerating there is a very small
cosmological constant it appears
but its value is way smaller than you
would expect it to have naively from
quantum theory you know in gravity
there's big g right which is just it's
just a number but it sort of encodes the
force of gravity in it somehow and so
this number lambda the cosmological
constant just enforce encodes this
repulsive force so the value of the
cosmological constant today is um about
uh it's a really small number if the
energy density the energy per unit
volume stored in the cosmological
constant
is about 10 to the minus 29
grams per centimeter cubed
so you and i are made up mainly of water
you know and that has a density of one
gram per centimeter cube roughly so the
the density the energy contribution of
this cosmological constant is amazingly
small 10 to the minus 29 that's
point
and then
28 zeros and a one
grams per centimeter cubed so why is it
totally why is it dominating it's
because it pervades the whole universe
it's constant throughout the whole
universe and the universe is very very
big so it adds to become a significant
contribution to the energy i i have an
open mind i think is the the right thing
to say in the sense that there is a
reasonable amount of evidence now that
this cosmological constant is there that
the universe is actually expanding at an
accelerating rate but it's not
overwhelming at this point
and the interesting thing about the
cosmological constant is that they're
actually only sort of
in a physical sense only two natural
values to give it one is zero it's not
there at all and the other is it's very
very large it completely dominates the
universe and what the evidence seems to
be suggesting at the moment is that
actually it's neither of those natural
values it's somewhere in between
and
at some level you know science is about
aesthetics and it's very anesthetic to
actually set that constant to this
arbitrary intermediate lowish sort of
value with no real science behind it
there are quite a few people don't
believe that it's
that it's there but it's got a zero
value i mean it can be there einstein
has demonstrated it can be there
but it could have a zero value
and
so one of the it's a big field of
research in cosmology is actually to
take seriously the idea that perhaps
einstein's theory of gravity needs
modifying and it's not that the we're
understanding the acceleration of the
universe because as a cosmological
constant but perhaps we've misunderstood
the gravity side of it the geometry side
if you like and uh lots of people are
working on what you call modified
theories of gravity where you you you
just like you change einstein's
underlying model adding in extra terms
which are usually to do with the
curvature of the universe curvature of
space in the universe
and you try and reproduce what looks
like the universe we see today